in a northern gazan neighborhood the
diggers are clearing the rubble of a
family home
[Applause]
it was where the alternatives live and
six of them are missing
it is difficult work and all the time
they know another airstrike could come
eventually the victims are found
a mother who was pregnant her husband
and their three children
all dead
there is a breathtaking destruction here
with artillery jets attack helicopters
and from the sea the israeli military
has been hitting buildings
and bringing them down
they continue to insist that they are
only targeting militants
but then compare the number of hamas
officials that have been killed
with the total number of people who've
died many women and children among them
there are moments here in gaza which
show an israeli attempt to limit
collateral damage
this man takes a call from an israeli
intelligence official
and it is an attempt to limit the loss
of life but still
imagine taking a conversation like this
soon after a small missile hits the road
they call this a soft knock
a last warning that there's an air
strike coming
and then it does
on the other side of the gaza fence in
fields a few miles into israel we
watched as israeli artillery fired off
round after round
well it's four days now since israel
began its retaliatory strikes against
gaza
that's four degrees of near constant
bombardment
and yet despite all this hamas has
continued with rocket attacks on israel
in this apartment block a five-year-old
boy ido avigal was the victim
and with this propaganda video hamas
claims they now have a new longer-range
missile which they fired at ramon
airport in the south of the country
it's where international flights are
being diverted after the main airport
was targeted
to the north in central israel the
country's prime minister fighting for
his political life a few weeks ago is
now casting himself
as the defender of the nation
the defense activity of iron dome
batteries is giving us an offensive
space and the idf
has already attacked hundreds of targets
we will soon pass one thousand
we continue striking hamas while
defending our citizens
it will take more time it will take more
time but with great firmness in offense
as well as defense
we will achieve our goal of bringing
back calm to the state of israel
and he does have a huge challenge israel
is a country more than shaken by the
hamas attacks
across the nation racial tension has
been stirred
jewish nationalists and israeli arabs in
street battles
lynch mobs are attacking each other in
cities and towns all over
[Music]
hamas's struggle against its occupier is
now being fought on the israeli streets
it has succeeded in helping create a
chaos within
tonight back on the border with gaza the
sky lit up
once again as the missile defense system
shot hamas rockets out of the sky
there is no sign of any let up mark
stone sky news
in southern israel